so for the love of George did you always
plan to have the crowdfunding campaign
be the sole production funds or did
their ideas no I mean the crowdfunding
campaign was something I say this the
started you know if I was gonna make a
short or a feature so we did the
crowdfunding campaign kind of just throw
it out there really to see what happened
but um it was seven weeks of extremely
hard work and at the end of it I you
know we got a certain amount of money
and it was a lot of money with which to
make it short but nowhere near enough
with which to make a feature and but at
that point I didn't want to make a short
and and waste it on sure so many people
I know were saying to me you can't make
a feature you can't do first you know
first feature you have to make short
first why don't you know what rule book
says anywhere you have to make a short
first and so many people that I knew had
made a short and regretted it and wish
it did you know they're now using that
there's a funding pitch for a feature
and so at that point I thought I really
want to make a feature you know let's
just let's go after that and this script
was being worked on and got better and
better and it the more it improved the
more I wanted to make it better and
better feature and and wanted to wait so
yeah it was something that I then had to
look outside a crowdfunding and and
start having meetings and approaching
people and like I say everyone in LA is
trying to do that but it's fairly easy
to get indoors in LA because everyone's
worried about missing the next best
thing you know it's a lot harder to
actually get anyone to commit or to get
funding or that side of it but I really
tried everything like you know I would
go to investors and film finances in LA
and you know had a few interesting
meetings where they would want to change
the script and they wanted to change the
husband and the husband should wait this
was one one male finance and I went to
see had very strong ideas about you know
how papi should behave towards husband
which I didn't listen to it all and he
didn't finance the film but erm you know
eventually it was just you try
everything you know I was trying I was
getting all these creative ideas about
how I was going to do funding and I was
going
go to country clubs and do fundraising
evenings and talk to people how they
could get involved in film which I
actually tried I tried you know doing
that none of it works you know but I was
really trying to get creative and go
outside the box in terms of you know
trying to get money within LA because at
that point I decided I didn't want to
give the rights up I didn't want to have
someone else you know make it through
their production company and for someone
to give me money to make it through my
production company it was a you know a
bit further down the line I realized
again well if I want this I'm going to
have to try and get the money myself so
that's what I did and so was this from a
series of investors or so from the the
crowdfunding yeah I think we had about
four or five investors and you know it
was really about relationship building
and finding people who could relate to
either subject or friends of other
investors and things and things like
that and yeah it was it was a very long
process and you know very time-consuming
and I can't tell you the amount of
emails I sent out like you know
thousands trying to find ways to raise
the money but you know I was very
fortunate in the end it all came
together and I had a couple of actually
females in particular that believed in
the project and believed in me and yeah
I'm very grateful for that
I almost envisioned some of Poppy's
character sort of what you were going
through and that everybody's in her ear
telling her kind of like what to do and
how it should be and I find that
interesting how did you sort of decipher
okay I'm gonna listen to this but this
person is probably very knowledgeable
and I'm sure they have great intentions
but I don't think this is for me and I
want to do it - how did you know who
listened - I think I I just have a very
you know strong belief that if you want
to do something that badly and if you
know if it's not something that's
completely delusional then you can
achieve it and you know I had people oh
you know you can't do a film about
George Clooney unless you're you know
you have a budget of 10 million and like
what sometimes I just think where do
these people get this stuff from
like who told
that because it's just blatantly not
true so I don't know I just I'm just a
believer that like I say if you really
put everything into it unless you have
some really random stupid idea then why
can't you do it you know who's to tell
me I can't and if I'm not getting
anywhere then maybe I'll rethink it but
let me try it let me try doing it my way